[Musik]
[Applaus]
apa
von christine jäckel kennt alle hier die
lehrerinnen sozialarbeiterinnen und
kinder der tagesstätte biasca land und
mich umarmt
naja ist die mongolische leiterin
die kinder kommen aus den judenviertel
dort wo die ärmsten wohnen
wieso sie trotzdem auf ein besseres
leben hoffen können davon handelt dieser
film
[Applaus]
[Musik]
christine jäckel besuchte kinder jedes
jahr diese tagesstätte hat sie vor acht
jahren in ulan bator gegründet
essensausgabe für 170 hungrige mäuler
guten appetit
eigentlich haben die kinder sommerferien
die meisten kommen trotzdem hierher der
freunde wegen aber auch weil es hier
täglich drei mahlzeiten gibt kultur
natur ist seit der eröffnung vor acht
jahren dabei jetzt hat der 18-jährige
die schule als jahrgangsbester
abgeschlossen und will studieren
ich würde mal in einer anwaltskanzlei
arbeiten dort sind die besten
da will ich hin
face
[Musik]
christine jäckel begleitet die
sozialarbeiterin bogy kubatur nach hause
die letzten beiden nächte hat er in der
tagesstätte übernachtet auf der flucht
vor den betrunkenen eltern wenn alkohol
gibt es wie in den juden vierte in der
mongolischen hauptstadt ulan bator jobs
sind rar
frust entlädt sich oft in häuslicher
gewalt christine jäckel temperatur seit
vielen jahren sein zuhause besucht sie
allerdings zum ersten mal
ich bin gespannt auf deine eltern guten
tag
das ist euer grundstück ja das ist die
otto meiner großmutter hier warst du
also ihr lieb zu dritt hier leben und
schlafen wie schläfst du welche wir
haben zwei matratzen die leg dir auf den
boden und wo lernst du doch da drüben
und die familie papa sieht fern und mama
putzt die eltern kennen bogy von früher
in hausbesuchen heute hören sie zum
ersten mal wie batur mit der schweizerin
spricht das macht sie stolz
ich bin auch stolz auf ihn ich weiß dass
du manchmal flüchtet weil deine eltern
streiten fighting naja wenn sie alkohol
trinken und streiten kann ich nicht
lernen
dann gehe ich zu barrios galant oder zu
meinen freunden
das letzte mal gechattet haben vor einem
monat gesagt dass du das ist wirklich
schwierig sein
hat sich etwas geändert zum guten oder
zum schlechten
hier kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren
dann gehe ich zu barcelona gut so bei
sachen dessen mutter und vater ertränken
ihre sorgen in wodka und raki der
mongolischen selbstgebrannten dann wird
der vater laut und gewalttätig davor hat
dass ältere schwester in jeweils
beschützt schon also so klein war wie
dieses nachbarskind wenn meine eltern
tranken und ihnen meine schwester und
ich oft nicht zu essen
guck vor mir aber meine schwester trieb
immer etwas für mich auf den oft hat sie
nichts
die agora und kochte nur für mich vorbei
es ist ohne meine schwester wäre ich
heute nicht hier eines besseren
[Applaus]
probleme direkt anzusprechen ist in der
mongolei ein tabu und doch bietet batur
christine jäckel um unterstützung
ich habe kein recht ihnen etwas vor zu
steigern aber es ist wirklich eine bitte
ich weiß dass alkohol sehr schwierig ist
dass man davon ist wie eine krankheit
ist aber das ist wirklich versuchen ja
einfach für sie übernehmen auch teilt
wirtschaft besetzt so höflich wie
möglich denn jetzt bitte kann als
einmischung in privates aufgefasst
werden
reparatur ist der appell lieben sich
wir sind erwachsene menschen
wir können jederzeit aufhören zu trinken
wir brauchen keine beratung von außen
soll ich noch mehr sagen
wie viele seen danke er kommt mit danke
dass du das gesagt hast für dich würde
ich alles tun aber ich wollte meine
eltern nicht beleidigen vorher reaktion
trinken trinken
das ist ein minus gemacht weil die sich
durch und hat mit dem einfach das
artwork und familie zeigen
die meisten der 170 kinder von bayers
galant erleben in ihrem umfeld gewalt
und missbrauch die tagesstätte in la
batu ist ein zufluchtsort war jasper
land heißt auf mongolisch glücklich seit
zweieinhalb jahren gibt es einen
kindergarten auch die kleinen sind
seitdem willkommen
so müssten deren eltern geschwister
nicht zu hause bleiben um auf sie
aufzupassen
naja hat wie viele mongolen in der
ehemaligen ddr studiert die tagesstätte
leitet sie seit anbeginn und weiß um die
geschichten der familien
es ist also wenn du kein vater hatte
keine mutter hat oder gerne verraten
hast also glücklich bist du wirklich
bist reich du wenn du geschwister hass
und eltern meist ja geld muss ich es ist
natürlich aber auch großer begriff also
die familien hintergrund ist es so
meisten dass die kinder kindergeld
bekommen sie unter statt und vermittelt
einkommen eine sehr sehr gering es gibt
sogar vermittelt denn nun mit dem kinde
geistern im monat auskommen
also kein offizielles einkommen ich
hoffe dass 20.000 locker das ist nicht
mal 10 schweizer franken androht kostet
umgerechnet einen franken 50 in den
jurten viertel am stadtrand leben viele
ehemalige nomaden gegen tiere im sommer
der türe und im winter der eisigen kälte
zum opfer fallen
hier leben die zugezogenen ohne
fließendes wasser und ohne kanalisation
christine jäckel hat in ulan bator diese
armut genauso kennen gelernt wie den
aufschwung vor ein paar jahren
sie sah wie das rohstoffreiche land
einen wirtschaftsboom erlebte der aber
bald wieder versiegt die gewinne
versicherten in den taschen des
sozialistischen garde die korruption
erstickte jede hoffnung auf wohlstand
für alle
heute sitzen die nachfahren jenniskens
auf einem riesigen schuldenberg
investoren tun sich schwer die soziale
schere zwischen arm und reich öffnet
sich als christin energie vor 14 jahren
als reiseleiterin in die mongolei kam
wollte sie straßenkindern helfen
zusammen mit anderen gründete sie einen
verein und kurz darauf wurden die ersten
kinder aus den juden vierteln betreut
bis heute stand das geld von schweizer
spenden ein wichtiges anliegen ist es
das selbstbewusstsein der kinder zu
stärken
da ist auch ein ständiger haarschnitt
ein weiterer hausbesuch steht an
sozialarbeiterin bogy fed christine zu
einer jute in der eine junge behinderte
frau lebt also kein lombok ihre
schwester liege oft allein in der jute
erzählten kinder in der tagesstätte
jahren fiel bubi anwandte zeigt
regelmäßig zu besuchen und zu pflegen
die 22-jährige ist zerebral gelernt aber
sie macht fortschritte
skype hat christine deren entwicklung
von der schweiz aus mitverfolgt
putin seit wochen für ihre schwester
sorgen und kann nicht mehr in die
tagesstätte kommen
eine große aufgabe für eine 7 jährige
die vor einem jahr den vater verloren
hat und die route sechs tage die woche
in der stadt putzt
ich finde es wirklich erstaunlich dass
twitter es sein essen kann
das ist genial das kann selber essen und
zu er hat auch kaum bewegungen gehabt
dass die ganzen finde es ist ein
bisschen schwer zum ist nichts man den
ganzen bereich weiß dass letztes mal an
wie viele tatsächlich ist das kann ich
jetzt ganz locker das passieren kann ich
auch so dass ich sind das freut mich
vorher habe ich einfach immer was
geweint wenn sie dann nicht mehr spielt
und habe da habe ich immer zusammen
geweint immer hört er nicht antasten und
bewegen und ich hab ich konnte nichts
machen das nur diese massage
weitergemacht und gehofft auch dass sie
auch besser geht aber jetzt denn wenn
ich das jetzt vergleichen sie tue aber
jetzt dass ich hab so ein gefühl
also sehe ich sie ist einfach sehr noch
im harz ist einfach mit mit jeden ort
also ich so früh also die ist so also
die ich einfach auch einmal kräfte frei
der lehre mit der tagesstätte sind auch
die kinder älter geworden
ein fonds des schweizerischen vereins
soll nun auch deren ausbildung im land
sicherstellen
ins büro herrscht krisenstimmung natur
lässt eine bombe platzen sei also was
gibt es für fünf tagen habe ich etwas
auf facebook gesehen natur bewahrt sich
über eine vermittlungsagentur für einen
studienplatz in taiwan beginn werde in
zehn tagen sein stipendium für die uni
ulan bator werde damit verloren und dann
hast du dich vor fünf tagen gegen die
uni von ulan bator entschieden
du gehst lieber nachteil waren ich
dachte ich versuche einfach und was
willst du mit mir besprechen
800 dollar ist die wie heißt das die
vermittlungsgebühr 800 für diese
vermittlung und 600 für drei monate
erst musst du chinesisch lernen drei
monate dafür brauchst du auch geld ich
misstraue menschen die einen mit 800
dollar für eine arbeit anlocken wollen
das klingt so einfach du weißt nicht wie
viel sie dir wirklich bezahlen und wir
haben keine zeit das abzuklären
wenn mein sohn würde ich glaub's nicht
und er ist wie mein sohn und rechnet
damit dass meine zusage nein sein wird
hier in ulan bator sind bauarbeiter um
ihr geld betrogen worden
du weißt nicht ob dir das in taiwan auch
passiert aber dort hast du keine freunde
niemand der die hälfte
vielleicht denke ich weiß aber dass
solche seite dem hartes leben durch
haben dass die so klingt glauben und
dann denken dass sie in ausland gehen
und dann bis ins leben hoffen und dann
so schon schwer das ist
lockvogelangebote also die jugendlichen
begleiten und unterstützen eine chance
kommt noch und sie motivieren trotz
schwierigem leben hier zu bleiben
so können sie ihrem land später etwas
zurückgeben
auch dafür setzt sich lisicki 106
familie konnte christine gäste rein ein
haus mit drei zimmern kaufen
zum ersten mal in ihrem leben wird warnt
in einem haus leben einzug ist ein park
des 22 geburtstags sie bekommt das
größte und hälfte zimmer wenn ich
arbeiten gehe mache ich mir immer sorgen
um wohnsitze aber jetzt ist es viel
besser weil sie hier in sicherheit ist
[Musik]
und für mich ist es eine sehr gutes
gefühl dass die logistik so ein schönes
haus ein großer platz bekommen hat ja in
zukunft der ich werde sie dann auch
besuchen immer wieder besuchen hier
besuchen
und da werden auch in den ganzen zimmer
spazieren fahren alles gute für dich
gesundheit und glück
am nächsten tag haben christine und sah
einen ausflug aufs land organisiert
in dem bus sind sie ungeschlagen
viele kinder kennen die stirn nase
zählungen und haben die stadt noch nie
verlassen
b
[Musik]
ist
naja sind ein traditionelles lied es
handelt vom kind das immer mit den
eltern leben will und von der natur wir
sehnsucht nach grünen hügeln und weiten
stecken
[Musik]
aber ich
95 kinder werden in diesem camp eine
nacht im zelt verbringen weit weg vom
newton viertel der stadt
[Musik]
und sogar für einen tag unbeschwert sein
solche erfahrungen sollen die kinder von
bayers galant stärken damit sie später
ihre probleme vielleicht anders lösen
können als ihre eltern gefragt was
realität machen aufs land und der wunsch
möglichst wenig im jahr hatte krebs land
und problem also das ist ja brücken
mussten tagelang auf das strahle die
spieler die sitzfläche sie ja jetzt
kritik spürte dass alles was sie könne
sie könne ja
überflutet